[Music]
thank you
what happened to me show starts by going
previously on and on about an entire
episode it did with a normal amount of
Rage in a completely abnormal amount of
flashbacks position another thing with
this previously on is that it is
inadvertently making an argument against
the existence of the last episode by
fitting its entire story neatly into the
first minute of this episode this is
like being the star witness in a case
against yourself showing up dressed like
Chris Angel and not doing magic or super
powered influencer Titania caused Panic
while fleeing traffic court super people
superfluously super fluency also why did
you use the same sketch twice if you
only have two use two or at least flip
the other sketch horizontally so it's a
little different kpvk news producers
better up their game if they want those
local Emmys a new superhero appears
responsible for stopping the Rampage
continued news position you can change
the channel is all you want but it'll
learn you the same sin not keeping your
orange slices handy members of the jury
are calling the green woman a hero who
saved lives damn it show here's five
cents for if even more news position I
didn't ask for second Exposition or
three or eleven Z's or afternoon tea you
get the bit that's for you
but why is it for her did they see her
coming have they been chanting this all
night are they superhero Hooligans how
drunk are these lawyers
come on no no no you mustn't leave out
Madame Hulk I can't even exist without
being a derivative of the Hulk that's a
pretty dumb name too Mickey would be the
excellent Hulk at TV sins no I did not
go to law school and rack up six figures
in student loans to become a vigilante
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
Thinking Child orphans can't be
Vigilantes MCU Spider-Man got his start
of 15 without billions of dollars or an
ounce of narcissism do the Avengers
offer health care I think having the
advanced regenerative capabilities of a
Hulk render needing Healthcare moot wait
did I just solve the health care crisis
hook blood for all oh no you did the
right thing but it unraveled our case
this did not unravel the case it
rendered the jury impartial sure but
since this occurred under unusual
circumstances the case should be able to
be retried with a different jury now
since I did not pass the lsats and I do
not know if it's a test that can be
passed I have to say that my
understanding of actual laws is not
nearly enough to confirm or deny the
validity of my previous statement
however when this court is in sin
session I am granted the leeway to
express my desire for a fair and
Equitable system that would not allow
for injustices like this to Prevail in
closing I am hoping this performative
yet most likely inaccurate legalese
would persuade you to rule in favor of
my client and the opinions of the common
citizen I rest my case no Jen I'm sorry
I have to let you go firing your
employee in a bar instead of waiting for
her to return to the office during
normal business hours pretty sure this
is a labor violation of some kind in
California and if it is isn't this is in
his California we can't hire a lawyer
who's such a big distraction in court
and what about this is this not an equal
employment issue I mean this feels very
discriminatory where is a lawyer when
you need one I mean that would really be
ideal if there was a lawyer around that
could explain this
oh well sorry it's a no if all these
people weren't going to hire Jen from
the start why did they bother
interviewing her it's not like she was
going to stop being a Hulk between the
interview and her hypothetical hire date
all you did was waste your time and if
the hiring process has taught me one
thing it's that corporations and HR
departments really value your time no
you can't work here they don't have good
snacks
Ginger Gonzaga is one of the best and
funniest parts about this show Winston
all for the best friend we could all use
in real life Disney in these [ __ ] QR
codes that they just love sprinkling all
over the place like all of them to
engage in such Shameless self-promotion
of their brand yep that's America's
booty right there and there's nothing
wrong with that but I posit a great many
of you have some booty pics on your
phone too and some of you might even be
looking at booty picks right now as you
listen to me Yammer on in the background
well I just want you to know that 100 of
those butts are either pre-fart or post
fart depending on when the picture was
taken so the sin as always is trying to
enjoy a butt next to a text from your
mom you know this much sugar is very bad
for you in your waistline oh I see we're
doing the mom body shames daughter
storyline that's bold and fresh let me
guess next she asks if Jen has a
boyfriend yet Chad Chad employed and
promoted writers have this family start
familying super hard straight out of the
gate instead of easing Us in with a
little foreplay so we have time to
acclimate and process the fact that I
just use the word foreplay while
referencing family so again uh that
Hawkeye guy what happens to those arrows
of his I mean does he go around and
collect them when he's done now there's
being meta and then there's cow Towing
to every silly question the internet
comes up with the proper way to do this
is to have Jennifer take on a case where
Hawkeye is being sued because because
some children found his arrows and poked
one of their stupid eyes out remember
you drink is this a bar that caters
exclusively to lawyers because so far
we've seen Kenny Nikki and her past and
future bosses All in This Bar when she's
here so I guess what I'm trying to say
is convenient bar timing is convenient
you got me fired now you want to hire me
actually you got you fired sure the
reason was [ __ ] but this man didn't
force you to turn into She-Hulk during
the courtroom struggle it's got some
office supplies to get you started
snacks and a map to the best bathroom
that is the nicest thing I have ever
seen anyone do for another person can't
come in like that no superpowers inside
her powers aren't a bow and arrow or a
metal suit that she can discard even if
you ever transformed back into regular
gin her powers are still inside her
ready to use at a moment's notice when
she transforms again this would be like
asking me to discard my unhealthy
obsession with sour apple flavored gummy
worms before entering a building I'll
pretend but so help me if one of those
green jellies of squirmy deliciousness
appears in the room it is over you're
gonna serve me up with some father beans
and advice
this is a prison that doesn't mean you
have to lock up the comedy
with seven soul mates that I met through
the prison pen pal program that I want
to start a new life with somehow my
elevator pitch for a new season of the
real world makes it into the episode
show wants us to remove a sin for
calling Tim Roth back from The
Incredible Hulk and we might have done
it if we weren't suddenly reminded that
we were denied Edward Norton in the
remainder of the MCU no shade intended
to Ruffalo but we'll always wonder what
could have been with Norton so here's a
sin for reminding us of that Captain
bloody America something you know tragic
but as we all know Captain bloody
America debuted in Falcon in the Winter
Soldier when he decapitated that guy
with cap Shield so bringing him up now
is a sin
show wants me to believe that Bruce Hulk
is able to answer this phone with those
hands when my mostly normal hands
couldn't even swipe right without
accidentally sharing my love interest
with a group chat comprised of every
contact I have in my phone I'm a
completely different person now
literally do your writers need to visit
an optometrist I only ask because that
last week was so hard I'm worried you
might have busted your retina but they
end up naming you anyway why doesn't he
know this with such big news that a
whole bar broke into chanting and surely
some family members would have posted it
on social media Bruce should totally be
in the know on this and before you say
that he's far away in space I will
remind you that he's currently talking
on a cell phone so he clearly has
reception I don't know why he has
reception but he has reception and
should be receiving the same news tweets
and Zillow notifications that he always
does I got some things I gotta take care
of
foreign
[Music]
I've already got a winning strategy and
it is a hundred percent in the bag
there's confidence and then there's
trying to jinx yourself which happens
almost immediately and we all saw it
coming you might want to take a look at
the news right now introducing us to the
ugly newspositional cousin of the better
come take a look at this cliche come on
up come on there you go being in the
neighborhood of the Beast
[Music]
Bill Lumberg it's about 10 o'clock
[Music]
uh wondering where you are maybe I
should have just let those people get
smooshed by that desk sweetheart Dolly
Parton wouldn't do that you got me fired
now you want to hire me to be head of a
new division yes so before you come back
here with another lame ass offer
I want you to think real hard about what
your spine is worth Mr Walker I made you
guys a welcome basket oh
with chocolate turtles with raspberry
jam and a little bit of fat and salt
this is in leave a message this is
Carmax I have intercepted sexual
Communications between you and my new
girlfriend Kiara I am coming to kill you
now but then you went on a destructive
Rampage in Harlem that wasn't sanctioned
by the government you don't understand
the metaphor I have here
uh various haikus that I've written oh
boy to each of my victims expressing the
sorrow Oh you don't have to if you'd
like to experience them that's okay you
think you're so smart with your fancy
little words this is not so hard huh
there you are
hello
this is George Peterson